à
au québec ça m'aurait coûté entre 32
mille cinquante mille dollars pour des
implants dentaires et en a une ça me
coûtait 12400 canadien logés nourris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la vitrine de cet opticien une
découverte inattendue des dentiers
d'occasion vendus juste à côté des yeux
de verre c'est une image encore bien
réelle de l'inde surtout en milieu rural
des dentistes pour les plus pauvres en
pleine rue mis en pleine chaleur dans ce
cabinet dentaire de mumbai on fabrique
des implants avec les moyens du bord les
mesures d'hygiène ne sont pas vraiment
au rendez vous des images qui contraste
avec une autre réalité de la santé en
inde des cabinets dentaires à la fine
pointe de la technologie qui n'ont rien
à envier à ceux de l'occident
un courage leur j'ai trouvé ça un
capital d'accor voudrait aussi sinon
plus avec genci bornes ne tarit pas
d'éloges sur les soins dentaires qui l'a
reçu en inde
l'accueil était très lien les chirurgies
sont venus me rencontrer tout en quatre
reprises et naturellement un moment
donné on aspire notre feeling puis mon
feeling était bon on est entre deux
choses le désir d'avoir des implants
dentaires et la crème qui pourra y
arriver quelque chose mais étant donné
que moi le désir était plus fort que la
crainte
j étais dans ce sens là
[Musique]
m
oui watts m
je ne
l'hôpital de chaîner où a été opéré le
québécois est une des vitrines des
ambitions indienne un établissement
ultramoderne qui reçoit des milliers de
patients étrangers chaque année en
provenance d'une centaine de pays
le nombre de touristes médicaux a triplé
en un deux puis 2013 et en 2020 ce
marché représentera une manne de 10
milliards de dollars pour le pays
au québec ça m'aurait coûté 1 32 mille
cinquante mille dollars pour des
implants dentaires et à aïn ça m'a coûté
12400 canadien logé nourri les indiens
ont trouvé l'astuce pour attirer le plus
d'étrangers possible jean six bornes a
été reçu par une infirmière qui parlent
français sur son site web spécialement
dédié au tourisme médical
le gouvernement indien recense 38
établissements capables de donner des
services en français et ce dans de
multiples spécialités de la chirurgie
esthétique à l'oncologie
en passant par l'ophtalmologie en fait
beaucoup de soin comme les ans un plan
des tombes âge les courants le docteur
rohit sharma reçoit des patients d'une
trentaine de pays dont plusieurs
canadiens ont pas donné la même qualité
en elle comme les autres comme dedans
ils ont canada ou aux états unis
parce que il ya beaucoup de sorties
c'est comme moi ici qui avait étudié en
états unis et nous avons la même
perspective le dentiste est accréditée
par l'ambassade des états unis
des inspecteurs effectué des visites
régulières pour s'assurer qu'il respecte
les standards américains
une bonne façon pour les touristes
médicaux d'éviter les mauvaises
surprises
je suis content un conseil puis me
permettre d'avoir d'avoir vraiment
d'état permanent je suis content d avoir
ça marche bien
puis pense à cette opération là je pense
qu'ils étaient pour moi être est
important depuis je suis content d'avoir
pris ce risque
[Musique]